my name is rene garcia frances cheney
I'm a junior in the department of civil
and environmental engineering and my
work concerns routing of drones and
communications constrained environments
so drones are being used currently more
and more to inspect infrastructure
especially after emergency situations
well there's two problems with using
drones to inspect infrastructure one of
them is that a lot of critical
infrastructure such as pipelines in
rural areas where 4G LTE or GPS coverage
might be spotty er and the second
problem is that in emergency situations
a lot of cell towers are down such that
4G LTE signal is unreliable so a problem
we're trying to solve is how do we
better route drones to inspect
infrastructure in these communications
uncertain environments and our approach
combines work in team orienteering
algorithms with kriging learning methods
such that the drones are simultaneously
inspecting nodes while also learning
about the communication space of the map
to learn what the communications
coverage is at different points and our
results show that there is at both an
increase in the total score at the end
of the simulation and also a decrease in
computational time towards at the end of
the simulation and this work could
ultimately be used to make
infrastructure monitoring quicker and
safer